[Musique]
sans faire un saut du coq à l'âne nous
allons maintenant nous diriger vers le
perche pour découvrir une activité qui
elle aussi a bien failli disparaître
mais qui grâce à des passionnés fait
plus que de la résistance
bienvenue chez sylvie bischoff à la tête
de la sellerie percheronne qui depuis 25
ans défend un savoir faire rare mais
précieux
[Musique]
avec mon mari on a démarré un atelier de
bourrellerie dans les années 80 3
bourrellerie que je sais pas si c'est un
os de terves disparu en fait il ya
beaucoup de métier dans le cuir il ya le
scellier qui fabrique les selles sellier
harnacheur qui fabrique des harnais et
le brûliez était plutôt l'artisan qu'on
trouvait dans tous les villages en fête
qui entretenait les harnais les colliers
pour travailler dans les champs pour
tout le transport qui se faisait avec
les chevaux jusque en 1920 et ensuite il
y en a encore eu un peu jusqu'en 1950
par ici en fait donc c'est un métier qui
avait complètement disparu
mais on a ressorti les vieilles calèche
dans les années 85-90 organiser des
concours de tradition ici saint-agil
étaient plutôt des concours d'élégance
avec toutes les belles voitures qui
était restaurée et e.on a remis du coup
le a remis au goût du jour
d'accord alors comment on retrouve le
savoir faire justement d'un mexique a
quasiment disparu
moi je suis complètement autodidacte bon
et c'est vraiment des montants les vieux
harnais et les refaire et c'est que j'ai
appris vraiment sur le tacle est donc
tous écoliers que vous faites ici
ici on en voit effectivement qui sont
très différents les uns des autres ça
c'est le collier anglais qu'en appel
du coup c'est plutôt le collier pour les
calèches légère il ferraille de seigle
en fait complètement à l'ancienne alors
c'est à l'intérieur
voilà et là par exemple on peut voir
donc ça ce sont des corps de colliers en
paille qui était fait donc pour faire
les colliers de travail agricole
d'autrefois ou de transport ou encore de
collège alors c'est un corps de collier
tout en pagne donc la paille accessible
sur le sol elle est formée en fait est
très très serré c'est très dur en fait
fait enveloppés dans du cuir et ça
faisait 15 ans - minimum 15 kg à partir
de 2000 on s'est rendu compte qu'on a
beaucoup de gens avaient envie de faire
des choses avec les chevaux en travail
agricole aussi mais en fait il y avait
beaucoup de mal à trouver un collier à
leur taille
parce que les chevaux aussi ont changé
en fonction des races en fait les gens
ont été poussés pour la viande dans les
années 60 80
donc en fait il n'avait plus la même
panne à tommy et tout donc on avait
envie en fait de faire un collier qu'il
soit léger réglable et
ouvrables aussi et avec un ingénieur en
aéronautique et un ami techniciens dont
la famille a toujours été dans les
chevaux percherons réfléchi voilà on a
laissé un voisin en fait on a réfléchi
ensemble on a travaillé pendant deux ans
en fait avec les réunions régulières et
cetera pour mettre au point deux coups
ce collier
l'idée c'est qu'ils fassent en dessous
de 10 kg et qu'il puisse aller sur
toutes les races de chevaux de trait
ardennais percheron et ses terrains
boulonné au lieu de rester
il y en a plutôt neuf bien connu et
après il y en a d'autres
un peu qu'il ait said émerger un petit
peu où il y avait pratiquement qui avait
disparu
[Musique]